technologies of disruption continue to
upend the way of things the nature of
transactions are being absolutely
upended the way in which supply meets
demand is being utterly transformed the
nature of business of the economy of the
marketplace is be flabbergasted by
disruptive technologies it feels like
the rug is being pulled from underneath
our feet and today my friends we enter
the age of the on-demand economy right
the philosopher Kevin Kelly who started
Wired magazine famously said access is
more important than ownership and what
do we mean by this what we mean by this
is that the magical devices in our
pockets these smartphones these miracles
of engineering these supercomputers
fitting the palms of our hands magic
mirrors that we rub with love and
longing
open up worlds of possibility in our
fingertips we literally live in a world
where we can decide I need a ride I need
a house and it has served up on demand
Alucard like an item from a menu in the
restaurant try to imagine as these
technologies continue to advance
exponentially where this means we're
heading we're moving into a world that
we build at the speed of thoughts we're
moving into our own imaginations as we
impregnate the world with sensors and a
eye everything will be served up to us
intelligently and intuitively without
any effort on our behalf sometimes
freedom means less choice we won't have
to waste cognitive energy making
decisions the world will simply emerge
as we love for intuitively
and subconsciously this is the magical
realm we're heading an on-demand
revolution where our imagination will be
served up by our technology miracles
will be engendered divine engineering my
friends is an inevitability of the human
enterprise
welcome to the on demand
Oh